foreign
to take a trip without them and some
comments my husband has made he's like I
don't really understand why you would
want to spend money on a trip for
yourself when we should be spending the
money on a trip or all of us as a family
absolutely not in no way are you selfish
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show the greatest mental health
in marriage and parenting and whatever
else is going on in your life podcast
ever
[Music]
man so glad that you're with us I've
been out of town for a few days and it
is awesome to be back with the gang
um and by the gang I mean everybody in
the booth and most importantly you guys
if you want to be on the show give me a
buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and if you're gonna be in
Nashville in the Nashville Franklin area
love for you to come visit and watch the
show live we got some chairs out here
and free coffee and
snacks that'll give you some of the
diabetes and you can come hang out and
it would be awesome to see you all right
so uh before we go to
my new friends Sammy so I recently had a
show and on the show I
was talking to somebody
um
about with a newborn with a kid
and you know I was someone who was about
to have a kid or was considering having
a kid was that what it was
yeah it was the guy that
um was nervous about having a kid there
you go okay okay and I made the
statement
um
you will never truly know the depths of
your ability to love until you hold your
first child
and
um usually
Instagram like social media is one of
two things it's like yeah bro you go
girl or it's
you're the worst person ever and I would
like to set you on fire
um and then occasionally I get really
thoughtful
um but I would say thoughtful good
engagement like pushback like I disagree
with that occasionally my friends like
Dr Norton will call me and be like hey
you botched that one big time here's the
reality
um but I sometimes will get some
thoughtful pushback and this particular
time
um was someone I've never met never
talked to I'm about to hear but it was
Sammy from Indiana and she reached out
and was super kind and um so Sammy I'm
gonna bring you in here Sam you there
yeah I'm here dude number one thank you
so much for even agreeing to be on the
show and to talk this through
um
I want to tell you out of the gate I'm
so grateful that you had the courage to
write in and say I think I disagree with
what you're saying and I I that meant
the world to me how you did it why you
did it and you gave some great
rationales like you I could tell that
you were
uh not just throwing grenades and so on
behalf of humanity who's all stuck in
this instagrammy world thank you for
being a good idea for being a good human
how are you yeah no problem I'm good how
are you doing good good good
um okay so I reached out back to you and
said hey would you I would love to talk
about this on the show because I I know
this particular
conversation is being had all over the
place and it's a good it's a part of a
broader conversation I've been
struggling with um as I'm trying to
write write a new book and try to dig
into some of the scholarship around this
stuff so
for everybody listening walk us back
through I make the statement on the show
you'll never truly know the depth of
your ability to love the depths of love
until you hold your first kid
and you heard that and you're in our
gang and tell me how that hits you what
you felt what you thought walk me
through that
and yeah don't spare my feelings by the
way let it rip okay
okay yeah so I've been listening to
every episode you've come out with and
it's just been a great place for me to
connect a different topics in my life
that I've been going through and so I
really respect you and what all you have
to say and I really take everything that
you say to heart so when you said that
it it kind of broke my heart a little
bit
um just because I hear a lot of that
talk in the world saying like you'll
never know love until you have a kid and
I think it just puts a lot of other
people who don't have kids into this
weird situation where we're less than uh
so tell me
so my wife and I struggled with
infertility for years years and years
um and so I I get that impulse tell me
where
um tell me why it makes you feel less
than
um because it feels like people think
you're only important if you have kids
and you won't contribute anything else
into the world unless you have kids
where does that story come from
um
I think I'm mostly hear it from parents
okay
um
yeah so a little backstory
me my husband have been married for
almost seven years okay and we always
like nonchalantly would say that we
would have kids
um but that always just got pushed back
and back and back and then my sister I
have an identical twin sister
um she had her first kid in 2020 and so
that's when everyone started bombarding
me but oh when are you guys gonna have
kids and that's kind of when we started
you know really thinking like is this
something we actually want to do because
it's a huge major decision that I think
a lot of people just don't take the time
to think about a lot so that's just what
we've been thinking about for the past
couple years and trying to make that
decision
so how has that is as y'all land on the
decision of are we going to do this are
we going to not
how is that how are you feeling pulled
in a less than position
um just the way that like some parents
and some other people talk to
people who don't have kids it's like oh
well you think you're tired well try
being up with a newborn and like always
trying to one-up people who don't have
kids or think that oh you're not going
through any anything hard in your life
uh or you don't yeah I'll give you
something to cry about right yeah yeah
okay okay
so
a couple of thoughts here I I I
absolutely remember that
and I remember I remember walking past a
room in our house and we had made the
decision to have kids and we couldn't
right so
um but we also didn't want to announce
that to the world I remember having a
hard hard conversation with a family
member and who said hey we've made some
decisions because you all clearly don't
want kids and it was like a knife to the
soul dude you know what I mean because I
was like well hold on like just because
you know I mean you made all these
suppositions about me and my my wife and
our family and
um so yeah that's brutal
um and I I want you to hear me say like
loud and clear
there there is no less than
right it's just simply different and but
I will say this
my wife and I were talking and she said
something once when she was first
pregnant with Hank and it stuck with me
and then I circled back to it when she
was uh it went another several years and
had a couple of wild surgeries and
wildness
um one life-saving surgery and then we
ended up with Josephine
she said I feel sorry for you this is
her talking to me I said why and she
said you will never know how close I am
to our son
I was like yes you have his dad
and she goes no dude he's been in my
body for nine months you'll never know
you'll never know what how close I am
breastfeeding kid in the middle of the
night just us two you're snoozing like
an old man like and I had to
there was a moment of yeah you're
exactly right I'm never gonna know that
and it doesn't mean that I was less than
or that I was dysfunctional or broken
but it was all it was just it was just
it just was a was right and so
what I'm wrestling with and you can you
can I'm hoping you can teach me I'm
wrestling with how do I
absorb truth in my life dude I had a dog
her name was Molly she was a basset
hound she was my hound dog she slept on
my pillow with me
um the joke in my house was she was in
my bed long before my wife was like that
dog was my ride or die I brought her to
meetings I brought that dog everywhere
and
um like I loved that dog I loved that
dog
I loved my friends dearly
and then I held my first kid and so I
don't feel like I'm in a place where I
can honestly say I understood what that
meant until
and at the same time how do I
communicate that without inferring that
it's somehow better than
it's just an is right like some pools
are three feet deep some pools are 20
feet deep
um depending on what you want to do with
your life pools are gonna be different
but I can't deny that pool's 20 feet
deep
so how how do I is it something that you
have to own that I'm not gonna let
people make me feel less than is it
something that I need to own when I'm
communicating to something we need to do
it together how do we how do we have
that conversation
I think it's it's both parties
um the one side who is the child free
couple you know like being firm in their
stance and saying like this is what we
want
um like we won't feel bad for it but
then I think on the other side it's for
people to accept that and to not you
know feel bad for them or think they're
less than or
um
like when you said you won't know you
won't truly know love until you hold
your kid there are other ways to love
people
um absolutely it's not the only formal
left like I understand it's a different
love so I think just for people who have
kids not totally summarizing something
and equating that to kids ah so maybe a
better way to say it was you won't ever
know the depth of
Your Capacity to love until you hold
your first kid but that doesn't mean
you're not gonna love deeply and wildly
and recklessly and like so there's
different yeah so I I can see where I
said that incorrectly because I've made
a blanket statement about love you'll
never know love until you've done this
that's not true
yeah right
huh okay that makes sense so on behalf
of myself
uh I apologize for saying it that way
because I made a blanket statement about
the nature of love that just simply was
inaccurate
um and I think I should have said it
differently and said
um and you guys listening I'm I'm
processing this in real time I should
have said
there's a depth and a capacity to love
that you won't understand until you
you're responsible for
um or to you hold somebody but that
doesn't mean you're not ever gonna love
right you're gonna have your spouse
you're gonna have your friends you're
gonna have your pets you're gonna have
whatever you're gonna love all sorts of
people
um yeah that makes sense I love that
okay so how do you on your side
um
how do you create a world where other
people don't get a vote
or very select few people get a vote
um I have
to have really tough skin over the past
couple years and is that a sustainable
is that a sustainable way to live it
seems like an exhausting way to live
no I think
thinking letting other people
have the freedom to my emotions and so
over the years I've
like the past couple years because I've
gone through a lot of hard things in my
life
um I've learned to
um what emotions do I allow to each
person
and so and that the whole kids subject
is one of them because I know that some
people will say dumb stuff because they
just don't know yeah you know they don't
know the situation I'm in so I let that
slide but then you know once someone
does know my stance then you keep
you know saying the same stuff then I
think that's where the education comes
in
could I recommend instead of looking to
form calluses
looking to because here's what I think
when I think um I'm forming calluses the
image in my head is of a tightening fist
I'm becoming hard and strong to this
instead of opening my hands even wider
and letting that kind of stuff pass
through me like air like a spirit right
um I I'm gonna make my way through life
not trying to be calloused as much as
I'm going to let that pass through me
like wind like that's not even a thing
you can say whatever you want and that's
not going to affect my mood or my body's
not gonna feel like it has to respond in
some sort of does that make sense
one of those feels like a lot of work
and the other feels like a infinitely
less anxious way to live
yeah I don't think I'm necessarily like
have like grew up as a kid who it was
very emotional and was you know let my
parents really control those emotions
and so as an adult I've had to learn
what do I allow people into well good
for you and how do I respond to things
awesome awesome awesome
um did you have you ever did you read
that uh on your past change of future
that book I wrote
um I started to and then my husband took
it and he started reading it and gave me
some Cliff Notes good job so I want you
to hang on the line I want you to read
it there's a there's a story in that
book um about my friend Lisa who was in
my one of my counseling cohorts and
um I'll I'll uh I'll end this call this
way
um we were sitting in a circle and I've
told the story on the show before we
were sitting in a circle as as
counseling classes do and we were
talking about you know different
scenarios different case studies and um
one of my great mentors and friends and
Professor Dr uh Brett Hendricks he laid
out
um a case study
and the case study was what happens if
you've been working with a client for
like six months and the client walks in
and looks at you and says hey you suck
at this
you've taken my money for six months I
paid you thousands of dollars I did your
little exercise with my with my romantic
partner and she left me I did your
little how to ask for a raise exercise
and my boss and not only didn't give me
the raise but gave me like a like a
reprimand you're not good at what you
and I was new to it right I was just
seeing clients in my practical and I
remember
saying out loud that would kill me that
would decimate me and
um Lisa who's one of the most wise she's
just awesome um she's brilliant she's
been a therapist for years and years and
years she looked at me and said John
they don't get that
and I rolled my eyes and I was like oh
gosh is that one like dumb counselor
speak and she said magic words you get
to choose who hurt your feelings
and I was like no that's not right and
she goes yeah other people can take away
your livelihood and are actually on the
way home I was thinking about this other
people could take away your livelihood
they can take away they can they can
um wreck your car they can take your job
away they can take your life away
but I get to choose who I give access to
my heart in order to hurt me and I asked
her like oh so how many people do you
give access to your heart you know I was
trying to rolling my eyes and she said
like five four five or six something
like that a very small number and so on
my on my bike ride home uh I'll never
forget this it was a hot west Texas
afternoon the wind was blowing it was
hot and I was riding my bike and I was
frustrated and I was trying to think who
would I allow in this little magical box
and I realized I was allowing everybody
I was allowing all my students all my
students parents all these
administrators all these people at other
universities I didn't know who were
colleagues
um I was letting internet people I was
like all kinds so I just started
whittling it down I took my parents out
and who I love I love my parents
but I took them out of the box I took my
in-laws out I took all these different
people and I got down to four or five or
six people and I remember
um calling a couple of them and said hey
I just want you to know I've given you
access
to my innermost being use it wisely
please
because if you tell me like hey you're
being an idiot you're being foolish or
you've made a terrible mistake I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna respond in kind
because I trust you and I'll tell you
this it was the single most freeing
exercise I've done in years
um I felt like uh like I was free if my
wife tells me something if my buddy Todd
like very select group of people if they
tell me something I'm in right other
than that people just don't get a vote
and I'll tell you it's like like I was
describing it's like opening your hand
up to the world and letting it just be
so
um I want to thank you for being so
thoughtful and kind in your response and
for calling me out and saying hey I
experience love and all over the place
and I don't have kids and so what you
said isn't accurate doesn't hold true
and the way I said that I still hold to
my my belief that the capacity for love
deepens when you hold your kid but it's
just simply dishonest to say you will
never know love right that's just not
true and so I want to thank you for
calling me out in such a uh dignified
and respectable way and I really
appreciate you Sammy
yeah thanks for um being able to listen
to all that I know some people don't but
thanks for being open to it of course
man and um hang on the line here and
we're gonna get you a copy of the book
and um that way your husband won't steal
your crap anymore he'd get his he can
get his own how kind will that be
awesome Sammy you're the best uh Hey
everybody hang on we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor betterhelp hey
look there's a lot of things we don't
get to choose on this wild ride called
life right the neighbor's kid learning
to play Trombone weird things trending
on the tick tocks or whatever that is we
don't get to choose the weather but when
you realize how much you do have a
choice in it's so empowering check this
out you get to decide who you want to be
I get to ask myself the question who do
I want to be you get to choose who
speaks into your life and you get to
choose to pursue meaningful
relationships this is life changing
stuff but I'll be honest it's not easy
these are new skills that we all have to
learn and therapy is a great place to
practice these new skills and that's why
I love better help better help is
Affordable online therapy that can match
you with a therapist quickly and it lets
you switch any time to make sure it's
the right fit and just like in-person
therapy it can help equip you with the
tools you need to work towards being who
you want to be because you don't just
have to let life happen to you you can
take it head on so visit betterhelp.com
deloney today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back
um
get ready everybody this is everybody's
favorite segment
facts are your friends here come the
tunes
get your bandanas and climb into the
Camaros with this rock tunes
this is like straight marble Reds
nothing else
just OG in a camo hat Joe's rocking a
camo hat it's a it's perfect all right
facts of your friends
2023 dating Trends revealed
now it's important for me to note
I haven't dated in a long long time
um several years ago I was back in Texas
and a buddy of mine had was divorced and
was dating again and so we were out to
lunch having a burger
and I was like all right dude I kind of
live it vicariously like what's it like
man you're like back out there what's it
like
I'll never forget man
uh he leaned across the table
and his eyes got kind of narrow like
lasered in and he said
I don't care what's happening in your
marriage figure it out
it's terrible out here and I started
laughing I was like what are you talking
about and he's like remember back in
college when you would see somebody like
you know out somewhere at some event or
you're like all hanging out whatever and
you saw somebody you thought they were
cute and you went up to him you're like
hey I'm John and uh what if I get like
what's your name and can I buy a drink
or you want to come sit with our buddies
you and your friends want to come over
he's like if you do that now it's
stalking they will call somebody on you
or they will like like cut eyes at
security and ask you to leave you can't
do that anymore you gotta go get
somebody's uh social information and
then stalk them for days or weeks online
and you just bypass the first one
through nine dates by I don't need to
ask you what your favorite music is I
just look through your your Instagram
reel and look at all the concerts you've
been to and all the shirts you wear like
all I get all your fashion I get all the
things you're into all your friends and
then after that you go on your first
date and then you just make out and so
he was like dude the whole thing the
whole thing's crazy it's all different
now and so I decided I was gonna work on
my marriage and so here we are 2023
years later dating Trends revealed this
is from dating.com
that sounds like a reliable source says
this data says resolution dating
inflation and metaverse dating
oh God Almighty we'll Define online
dating in 2023
the article says
um there's not there's not an author
here it just says uh Yahoo finance
singles are looking for partners who
help them stay true to their own New
Year's resolutions
singles are continuing to rely on
technology to make new connections and
to build relationships so I could see
that like if you or somebody you know we
talk about
um I'm going to create some new
identities and then I'm going to
backfill my new identity with actions
that lead me towards right so I'm a fit
person I'm a person who takes care of my
body I'm going to date somebody that
maybe wants to go work out with me or go
hiking with me or go for walks
um or somebody that if I say hey I'm
going to I'm gonna get a burger without
the bun they're not like oh my gosh
I'm gonna date somebody that's going to
lead me towards my goals that makes
sense to me
um and singles are continued around rely
on technology to make new connections
and to build relationships I call
bullcrap on a stick in a box on the back
of a pony riding through the desert on
that one I think that's not true we'll
get to that later
um it goes on to say in doing so the
goal is to find a partner that aligns
with and supports your own personal
goals whether they're related to your
career Fitness hobby or new skills that
you want to learn
here's what I'm I it makes me
uncomfortable about this
anytime you are making changes you're
working towards goals let's say you want
to run a marathon training for a
marathons it's awful it's just long runs
right sometimes it's cold sometimes it's
hot sometimes the runs are awesome and
they feel great but it's training's hard
right
um getting out of debt is hard I have to
say no to everything and put all this
money I'm making and I'm working side
hustles and extra jobs all that money is
going to pay a credit card off for
something I bought a year ago or five
years ago or a college class I took 10
years ago right so accomplishing a goal
is hard and when you
meet somebody and you and and their
current version of themself aligns and
supports your own personal goals it
becomes utilitarian I'm gonna align with
you because you are gonna help me get to
where I want to go and as I'm going
there it's going to be uncomfortable and
I my fear here is I'm going to project
my discomfort unto you and so I know
it's a balance right you don't want to
meet somebody you don't want to date
somebody who's
um vision for their life doesn't align
with you at all but this is a lot of
pressure to put on a new person that
you're just meeting and the chances of
you
getting frustrated along the way as you
become somebody who I'm a vice president
kind of guy so I'm gonna start doing
vice president kind of things that's
awkward and hard as you make that
transition and it's real easy if you are
leaning on somebody that they get the
brunt of the discomfort they become a
source of blame or frustration
um 55 percent of respondents rated
common goals and values is more
important than physical appearance and
attraction
looks like we're growing up okay then we
went to a resolution dating sixty
percent
um noted that they would pump the brakes
on a relationship if the partner's
behaviors or habits were hindering them
from reaching Fitness and Wellness goals
I don't understand that
mainly
I guess I do I guess I do I guess if
every time I worked out my wife was like
you're the worst I hate you I that
probably wouldn't pode well or if I
wanted to eat healthy and she was like
more marshmallows that probably would go
well either
um here's my concern so
when I started uh grad school my wife
and I were both in graduate school at
the same time and let me back up when I
was a kid my mom went back to college
late in life and she is a mythologist so
she was studying mythology and she was
she learned Old English and she was
reading some of these original
Shakespearean texts and their old
original language all this stuff so my
mom was all into this and I was like 16
17. and I'd be watching like the Astros
and my mom would get in front of the TV
and mute it and be like you guys gotta
listen to this and she would read us
something in Old Shakespearean Old
English or Middle English I don't know
what Shakespeare's written in and she
was dying laughing like it was some
great inside joke in King Lear that I
didn't get as a 16 year old and I
remember being like Oh my gosh this is
ridiculous and I also very clearly
remember my mom was in heaven she loved
it so fast forward my wife and I are in
grad school
I remember like one day we were out to
dinner and I was like Hey listen I'm
studying student development theory and
how colleges operate you are studying
reading literacy and how children's
brains learn to read I will never ever
care about that and you are never going
to care about what I'm studying could we
just make a deal now that we will never
talk about what the other person's
studying could that would that be
amazing and I thought she was going to
weep with joy she was so excited she's
like oh God yes I hate talking to you
about whatever this nonsense you want to
talk about and so we made an agreement
there like let's just not ever talk
about it and then over the years
like we shared a laptop for a long time
before everybody had their own laptop
and I would open up the laptop and she'd
be working on an academic paper she was
sending for publication and I would read
a page or two and I remember being like
who are you how do you know all this
stuff she's amazing and over the years
I've realized I think that was a mistake
I think I screwed that up then fast
forward to now I'm in a totally new
industry I'm learning about mental
health issues of talking to hundreds if
not thousands of people every week and
um or for show listeners dozens right
there's only like 18 of you out there
um and so
I just had a conversation with her uh
about a few weeks ago said hey we made
this deal a long time ago
I want to be able to talk to you about
my work and I want to hear about what
you're working on and the things you're
experiencing and so we are having to
learn how
to meet different needs as we've moved
our relationship on so why am I telling
you all that
it's if you're dating somebody
if you say like this person is going to
help me meet my goals and needs what
happens over time if those goals and
needs change and so I want you to
obviously focus on somebody's going to
help you with your with your goals and
ease and not lean on them too much like
we talked about earlier but also
be willing to be with somebody look for
somebody who is holds the world very
Loosely has some very strong core values
convictions but holds beliefs and other
things very loosely
man I was a vegan at one time and then I
was full keto one time and now I've got
more I I've developed a a different
protocol that works better for me and
don't come after me vegan and keto
people
but I'm a person that likes to say I was
wrong and I like to find out when I was
wrong I like to change my mind and my
wife is too and so more important than
being with somebody who helped me meet
my immediate goals I'm with somebody who
supports me wherever I head off into the
woods
and who's walking alongside me and I do
the same
and our religious beliefs have diverged
over time our political beliefs have
diverged over time we've changed we've
become different people in multiple
different Arenas and so if you're
looking for someone like I'm a fitness
person and I only will date a fitness
person that's cool but there may come a
day
when going to CrossFit seven times a
week turns into I've got two little kids
and a full-time job and I've got a small
little home gym where I crank out 40
minutes four or five times a week that's
what I can get done
and if those people I only were CrossFit
people then you're gonna have some real
problems and so I want people to
resolution dating cool
um that seems very short-sighted
um tight budget means monogamy I love
this
61 of singles are opting to date one
person at a time versus meeting multiple
potential Partners simply to save money
on first dates
way to go America
um transitional dating 33 of singles
plan to date in the okay listen listen
this is the one that gives me
hemorrhoids
33 of singles plan to date in the
metaverse
in the metaverse
that's not real
that's not a thing
here's the thing about the metaverse
it's not real
uh using avatars to put a bigger
emphasis on communication and I love
this digital intimacy before in-person
discovery
few things in the world give me the
heebie-jeebies more than the phrase
digital intimacy
I can't recommend against this enough so
I want you to go on a thought experiment
with me
up until all of human history up until
the invention of the radio
and then fast forward to podcast
I talked to callers live callers on this
show and we have back and forth we talk
about intimate things and deep things
and we're having a human interaction
up until all human history until just
recently like a snapshot 100 years 200
years
you had to be in the room with a group
of people
to have this level of insight into these
intimate conversations
someone could relay them to you but you
couldn't hear them live and now we have
podcasts and earbuds and you can be
vacuuming
having a ringside seat to a conversation
that in all of human history you would
not have been able to have access to up
until just now
similarly like think of photographs
our brains are not wired to see pictures
of ourselves when we were five that is
brand stinking new
and so
we have the illusion of
intimacy and I know this because I talk
to people out in the in airports and at
Live Events and people will come up and
tell me things about their husbands or
their spouses or their sex life and I
often will go
whoa I don't know you like you're
telling me a lot and we're in a public
place I was peeing at an airport in an
airport bathroom
and a dude came to the stall next to me
I'm peeing I'm just looking at the tile
ahead of me like you're supposed to no
eye contact don't be weird just looking
at the tile
and the guy I guess looked over and was
like Hey you do John deloney and I was
like yeah man I'm peeing
and he goes dude I love your show
still peeing and then he goes hey man so
my wife and I just stopped I stopped him
and I was like hey man it's not a good
time and he goes oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and here's the thing
his body
knows it was like has his body
understands that we are friends that we
have a connection
because he listens to the show he knows
about my kids he knows what makes me
laugh he knows our J my jokes he knows
how stupid I could be and how like not
good at Radio I am and how good at
podcasting him he knows all those things
because he's internalized him and his
body has this false sense of it
connection it's not real it's not real
it is real but it's not real so I tell
you this to
don't date in the metaverse
because
you can transmit information digitally
I can transmit the words I love you I
can transmit pictures of my naked body I
can transmit pictures of my home in my
childhood I can send you info
but our bodies are co-regulated I only
know where I am in space because there's
another living being in my presence
and so this it creates this Mass
illusion that's not real in different
parts of your body think it's connected
and other parts don't and we are
dude we are dancing on the nuclear
buttons when it comes to our physiology
combined with technology combined with
their neurology and psychology it's
Madness
so I cannot tell you I can't tell you
enough
don't date on the metaverse
if you play Legends of Zelda dude games
rad it's cool play Zelda
get out of the metaverse and find ways
even if you got to use an app to swipe
right swipe left whatever
connect with real people in the real
world
you owe it to your body I'll say it this
way there's no such thing as digital
intimacy it's not real
it's not real have human intimacy so
that's the 2023 dating trends
[Music]
Kelly this just makes me sad
good luck everybody
we'll be right back
all right so we're back
um hey John yes so you were talking
about somebody coming up while you were
peeing yes I've got a little similar
story
so quite a few years ago when I worked
on Dave's show
um my former obi-gyn and I say former so
I'm in the office in the startups exam
is happening
and he realizes where I work so he
starts asking me 401K questions
oh my God so I had to say that um hey
can we have this conversation when I can
see your eyes yeah
not now so some people aren't that aware
no metaverse dating no metaverse dating
and no talking about sensitive topics
insensitive moments is that the way to
say that that's fair trying to be
sensitive because some people let their
kids watch this show listen you should
don't let your kids listen to the show
all right let's go to lyanna lyanna and
Virginia what's up Liana
hi how's it going so good how about you
I'm doing well trying to keep my kids
from listening to the show a little bit
good for you you're a good parent you're
a good parent they they enjoy the peeing
stories though so that's always fun okay
that's my wife tells me my humor kept
out at about 11. so perfect
uh you're not dating in the metaverse
are you
happily married
good in the real world you're married to
like a human
a mechanic so he's very real world oh
very real world excellent excellent okay
so what's up Leanna how can I help
so I am my question was
um am I selfish for wanting to take a
trip by myself without my wonderful
husband in my
um kids
um a little back story so I have two
kids I have a four-year-old and an
almost two-year-old
so I'm kind of in the middle of it all
um I am a part-time realtor and a
part-time MLM consultant and I'm in
school full-time taking 17 credits right
now
um online
so there's not really a whole lot of
down time for me I feel like really the
only time I can get away is during the
very short deer hunting season that we
have here in Minnesota
um your deer hunting season is absurd by
the way
[Laughter]
so you know I feel selfish for wanting
to take a trip without them and some
comments my husband has made
sometimes makes me feel even more so
tell me what those comments are
um well it's mainly like he does this
dirt bike truck
s and he's like oh it costs like hardly
nothing just the gas for the dirt bike
and and maybe some food so he's like I
don't really understand why you would
want to spend money on a trip for
yourself when we should be spending the
money on a trip for all of us as a
family and so then I'm like okay why is
it why is it either or
that's what I don't understand either
um you know before his his knowledge or
thoughts were he couldn't keep me safe
and I grew up in a military family I can
keep myself plenty safe
um yeah yeah
um yes the deer need to be worried about
you so let me I'll just answer this
directly absolutely not
in no way are you selfish I just listen
I just finished
um I just finished three months of what
I would call hell of of right book
writing hard it's just like getting up
at 5am going to work and then heading
off into a dark hole by yourself and
getting done at 10 or 11 at night it may
have been month after month on the road
riding in hotel rooms it's been chaos I
just hit send on the manuscript last
week
and
that weekend I got I mean on Wednesday I
got on a plane and flew to Utah to meet
up two great guys
um Dustin and Steve and I went with a
buddy here that I work with at Ramsey
and we went on a hunting trip in the
middle of nowhere Utah
and on the surface it could be I felt I
felt what you're feeling and felt a
little bit selfish
it was the most important thing I could
do because I had to go clear the cobwebs
so that I could come back and be present
otherwise my kids and my wife become
another task right they become just
another thing in order like I got to do
my classwork I gotta do this I gotta go
hug my kid I gotta go show up to the
school thing I got to make sure my
wife's happy
and they deserve more than to be part of
my checklist
right and so it's critical
that we get away and separate and I
absolutely love love when my wife goes
to hang out their friends she comes back
renewed and refreshed and she's got new
thoughts and new ideas I love it love it
love it
um and it sucks because yeah right I
gotta do bedtimes and morning times and
breakfast to make sure people are
putting on deodorant and making lunches
I gotta do all that I don't like doing
that and
um but it's part of being in a
partnership right it's part of being
married
um
I I I think going down the road of but
my trip cost this and why does your trip
come that's Dangerous Ground that's
comparison man and that's just that's
just gonna melt uh it melts of marriage
every time marriage can't be 50 50 like
that well you spent this much so I get
to spend this much it can't be like that
otherwise it just becomes this tit for
tap Ness forever and man you can't build
a relationship on that
right well and I feel like that's what
he saw growing up since his mom would
take trips and now she does trips with
her daughter-in-laws and then my
father-in-law would go on a canoe trip
in The Boundary Waters with the boys and
it'd be a very you know less costly than
what hers were but they'd be arguing
about it and that's just what he saw
yeah I think it's I think it's important
to call that out this is what we both
this is what you saw growing up this
isn't how we're gonna do this
because the thing that brings you Joy is
I don't know what trip you want to go on
a cruise like getting away getting out
on the Open Water that's a thing and the
thing that brings you Joy is riding
motorbikes across the country I mean
across the state yeah by the way
motorbikes are expensive and so maybe
the trip itself is inexpensive but all
in like I can do that I can have this
really fancy Sitka gear that I got good
grief it's like an Armani suit and I can
have really fancy like hunting equipment
and then I can be like hey my trip don't
cost nothing I'm just going out to sit
in the woods for a few few hours that's
ridiculous right right so my cost is
just all on the front end and my wife
may spend nothing ever ever and they
want to go on a cruise or go hang out
with their friends but dude I think
that's amazing it goes back to putting
your oxygen mask on first here's the
only time I'll call you out okay
is if you are going on this trip to run
away
hmm okay
um if you use if you are out of capacity
and you feel like you have to escape
them
one is running from a thing one is
running towards a thing and it can look
very similar but here's what happens if
you run from a thing you're going to get
a cabin somewhere with a couple of
girlfriends and you are going to end up
doing nothing
right and you're going to get frustrated
that you didn't fee that you showed up
with you you went with you back to your
house
right so I'm gonna go on a vacation for
a very specific reason I'm gonna go and
take five books and sit in a cabin for
three days and do absolutely nothing and
my goal is restoration or I came back
from my trip more exhausted than when I
left I right it was eight degrees
outside it was freezing we were hiking
through snow up mountains it was Madness
um so I came back more exhausted but my
goal wasn't to go get restoration my
goal was to go hit control delete right
right and so I planned that going into
it
okay yeah and I feel like restoration is
definitely needed maybe there's a little
bit of the Escape idea but more so just
because
2022 was a terrible year
um and I just need a break basically
what I do is I wake up in the morning
and immediately start going going doing
real estate things handling kids and and
making sure everything's good in the
house and then when everybody goes to
bed I'm up for three or four hours doing
school yeah yeah so some of that is some
of that is yeah absolutely and some of
that seasonal right you are going to
graduate
um the real estate market is on a
dumpster fire right now and it will come
back right right so you're in a you're
in a wild season right now
more broadly speaking
I'm more concerned that once those
things level back out you're going to
find more stuff just to fill them
um my friend Ian Simpkins he's a pastor
here in Nashville he said a line
recently that just melted me he said if
busyness is your drug rest will feel
like stress
okay and if you're creating a world that
is super busy all of the time on top of
the busyness of just being a mother of a
few young kids
you're going to cross the line the
graduation stage and you're going to
immediately feel that that void with
more crap
yeah I want you to build a life you
don't have to run away from
yeah and go away and have fun and enjoy
your life right go go on a trip and
um I'm not gonna lie my wife says I
don't vacation well with you sometimes I
need to go away by myself for three or
four days with some friends there's a
little piece of me that hurts my
feelings like I wish I was like I wish
she was like you make me calm and you
bring me restoration but I'm a little
bit not like that I I a little bit more
chaotic right and so yeah I wish I
wasn't I do I do I just am and so the
next best thing is I can honor her and
be super excited that she's going to
take care of herself and she's yeah
um getting restoration and all that kind
of stuff that makes sense yeah that
totally makes sense I appreciate it
thank you so much got it so here's your
homework assignment okay homework
assignment is I want you
to get by yourself go get coffee and I
know this is a tall order even if you
got to get up half an hour early okay
you'll be super tired
um have an extra coffee this one
particular morning and I want you to
write down
your needs
okay here's what I need in my house and
usually for a mom in your situation
I need help with the kids and I know my
husband's working really hard but it's
just not me in school when I go to
school we're both in school
and
it's not just I have three kids we have
three kids and I know he's working hard
and I still need some help and I need to
get three days so that I can go just
laugh and cut up with my girlfriends I
need three days so I can just go scare
off into space and whatever awesome and
if he comes back with
um well then I get my three day I your
response needs to be honey I'm not in
competition with you
yeah I'm not competing with you we're
not going to go back and forth we're not
on a teeter-totter here
what you need you you need and what I
need I need and I want to learn how to
say my needs out loud and us together to
figure out how we can both meet those
does that make sense yeah that makes
sense completely and I know that can be
a pipe dream for some folks I know
because I know that some husbands or
wives or whatever just I ain't doing
that
I'll tell you if you're listening and
your romantic partner your spouse comes
to you and says
look I
I need this or I really want to take a
trip with my girlfriends I want to take
a trip with my the guys
[Music]
try it just once and say that's amazing
can we plan the can we plan the exit
like what the a couple of days before
you go can we plan the re-entry a couple
days after you get back can we plan what
that will look like so that we're all on
the same page and I could best love and
honor you as you come back as you go
right
um could we do that together that'd be
amazing
um try
it's practice just try it once and if
it's a disaster that's on me try once
been excited even if you gotta fake it
I'm all in I'm all in
go have your trip go have fun get away
you deserve you've been working really
hard I'll pick up some slack when you
get back
um
I'll be excited to see you try that
instead of what about me that's
expensive
and
give the gifts of uh support
try that we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we're back and as we wrap up
today's show today's show is a little
bit rambly huh got all over the place
um this is Kelly's favorite breakfast
song she sings it every morning at
breakfast with a big smile on her face
it's her happiest time of the day
songs by the great Rupert Holmes
I don't know if he's great he may be a
terrible human I don't know by Rupert
Holmes
the song's called Escape
the Pina Colada Song
Rupert writes and Kelly sings I was
tired of my lady we've been together too
long like a worn out recording of a
favorite song so while she's laying
there sleeping I read the paper in bed
in the personal columns there was a
letter I read
if you like pina coladas and getting
caught in the rain if you're not into
yoga if you have half a brain
if you like making love at midnight in
the dunes of the cape then I'm the love
you've looked for right to me and Escape
[Music]
and that's when Kelly goes running out
the house
every single morning
I love you I'll see you soon don't date
the metaverse God almighty